[Music]
how do you celebrate your birthday when
your Courtney Cox with a slow-mo bikini
insta post duh I love everything about
it
on Monday the friends alum hit up
Instagram to ring in her 56th bday in an
epic way I know warning it's about to
get hot in here
yeah that's court in a teeny tiny black
two-piece jogging in slo-mo then diving
into a pool is anyone else getting major
Baywatch vibes
[Music]
anyway the birthday girl captioned the
sexy clip quote gracefully diving into
this next year yeah that dive was like a
four out of ten on the grayscale but hey
she looks amazing and we applaud the
athleticism really excited naturally
some of Courtney's celebrity pals like
Whitney Cummings David Spade isla Fisher
Chelsea Handler and Octavia Spencer
wished her a happy birthday in the
comments but it was Rachel's oh who said
what we're all thinking
you look fire courts friends co-star
Lisa Kudrow took to her own insta
account to post a sweet tribute sharing
several pics and writing
happy birthday Courtney Cox my genius
generous gorgeous grounded great good
friend I love you the court isn't the
only member of her family celebrating a
birthday over the weekend the actress
shared a sweet throwback video of her
daughter Coco Arquette she captioned the
clip quote happy sweet 16th Coco low
you're my little quirk of the universe I
love you your eyes are really hard to
work with mom Courtney and Coco have
been posting a lot of mother/daughter
content lately like this clip of Coco
doing her mama's makeup either the
eyeliner there something wrong with your
eyeballs I can't tell the two have also
rocked some major choreo on tick-tock
[Music]
and covered burn from Hamilton
[Music]
impressive right and no surprise here
court told et that her daughter might
just be following in her showbiz
footsteps Coco's really she's into
musical theater and she's done probably
twenty two plays already she's
absolutely obsessed and maybe more than
her schoolwork she was in the Addams
Family and she just got the part of Mimi
and rent so she's really excited so yeah
that's her passion and I would do
anything to continue to help support
women in his industry so she doesn't
have any the same issues and she has all
the opportunities that she deserves
Cortney shares cocoa with her ex-husband
are ket who recently gushed about their
teen and her talent to et she's
incredible she's got more talent than I
ever had or ever could ed confidence
which is really amazing
[Music]